wir stehen hier direkt am kurfürstendamm
in berlin wo sich das ganze abgespielt
hat es ist vor dem restaurant franco
jeas passiert in prominenten lokal wenn
man den augenzeugen trauen kann und
glauben kann dann müssen sich hier
wirklich horror szenen abgespielt haben
eine dieser augenzeuginnen historiker
sängerin aus berlin zur therapie kam ist
dass du gestern hier das alles
miterleben musste
ich war eigentlich auf einem foto
shooting und hat dann eigentlich bis
dahin noch ganz schön aber auch
anstrengenden tag und ich saß mit meinem
manager direkt vorne irgendwie im
restaurant und wir haben zu abend
gegessen und wollten eigentlich auch
schon gerade gehen und hörten dann haben
wir schon gehört dass hier ein auto
wahnsinnig schnell lang fährt man hört
ja solar asa und das ging alles
wahnsinnig schnell dann hat ja den
silbernen kleinwagen erfasst ich weiß
nicht ob der kleinwagen überfahren
wollte oder ob er abbiegen wollte
der hat den halt hier auf der kreuzung
getroffen und der wagen flog halt dahin
auf die straße also wirklich weit
das unfallauto ist dann hier in parkende
autos gecrasht hat hier die alle
zusammen gedrückt und zusammengeschoben
und das auto hat sich überschlagen blieb
irgendwie auf der seite auf der tür
liegen
hier flog alles durch die gegend überall
glas autoteile sind durch die gegend
geflogen
alle natürlich total in panik sind
aufgesprungen erstmal das so realisiert
man ja gar nicht so schnell dass wir
wieder und dann sind natürlich alle
erstmal zu diesem auto und haben geguckt
irgendwie was da los ist und da waren
zwei frauen in dem auto und die eine hat
so wahnsinnig schlimm geschrieben also
ich habe noch nie in meinem leben so
eine schreibwerkstatt wirklich wirklich
schlimm die eine passt also die eine
haben sie dann haben passanten noch
rausgezogen blutüberströmt irgendwie auf
die straße gelegt und dann kam langsam
die feuerwehr und die polizei
alles war voll alles war panisch
aufgeregt natürlich weil das ist einfach
dort rechnet man ja nicht ja und dann
hier mitten auf dem kudamm einfach
also ich habe noch nie so etwas gesehen
noch nie so was gehört und dass wenn ich
jetzt auto fahre bin ich selber noch
also ich bin total
nun ist es ja auch so dass wir ja in der
nähe saß das heißt hier kein auto
gestanden hätte wäre ja der bmw genau
hier ins restaurant geknallt und du
sagst dir direkt auf der terrasse
absolut das auto entweder das was sie
getroffen wurde hätte auch hier dann
fliegen kann statt da lang und auch der
der unfallverursacher wenn der wenn hier
kein auto geparkt hätte was hier glaube
ich eigentlich nicht keine parken dürfen
dann wäre halb voll karacho es ist das
gefühl wenn man daran denkt dass man
selbst das ist ein selbst hätte
erwischen können
schockierend also es wird ein auf ich
habe die halbe nacht nicht geschlafen
weil ich kann zu hause anderen film so
aufgewühlt dass das ist einfach und das
ist einfach unglaublich dass die leute
hier immer noch so lang rasen und damit
einfach andere menschen gefährden
[Musik]